[Music]
let's go to ruth in san antonio hey ruth
what's going on
oh well i'm a big dave rimsey person and
i have your book i've listened to a
couple of times
uh recently back in january i have been
taking care of my mother who had
dementia for two and a half years
unfortunately she developed coveted and
passed away in january
and i'm excuse me i'm trying not to get
upset oh you're good i'm
i'm the executor of the estate
and i have
two siblings that are making it very
hard for me they're you know you should
have done this you should have done that
and
recently they're accusing me of stealing
money from my mother and uh
i'm not really sure how to handle it and
like i've requested bank statements so i
can go back and say oh hey look here's
where this money is here's what this
money is and it's kind of funny because
for two and a half years they said
nothing no one ever came to see her it
was up to me to take her to see him
and now it's
well you know
and so that's kind of my terrible story
oh i'm so sorry yeah i'm so sorry so
ruth a couple of things here number one
i'm so sorry about the loss of your mom
um
have you had a chance to exhale and sit
in that
i had good days and bad days and
yesterday was a bad day because i had to
hang up on her because she was telling
me that she hoped
i could live with myself and that god
could forgive
pray for god to forgive me for what i've
done to the family and i'm like i took
care of my mother that's right
so bad so um listen you are not solving
a math problem here
this is not a forensic issue
i'm gonna give your brother and sister
the benefit of the doubt
and say that i'm going to assume they
are struggling with guilt over not being
there for mom that they are heartbroken
that their mom's gone
that every time they see something on tv
about another covet death or another
thousand covet deaths or
that brings up mom
and they are choosing unfortunately to
channel that guilt and anger and sadness
and heartbreak at you
do you deserve that no and again i'm
giving them the high benefit the doubt
the the low benefit that is their jerks
and their complete scumbags and they
went and had a drink one night together
and thought hey man let's get our hands
on some of mom's money
i don't want to go there
but you can go get bank statements and
do forensic accounting and all that kind
of stuff i wouldn't spend my energy on
that unless they sue you
what you're trying to do is prove
yourself to you
and you don't need to do that
often when people are taking care of
folks
who have dementia
you watch the most important person in
your life slowly
slip away
and it's really painful because it's
like a slow motion accident and it just
slips through your fingers
and it's almost a slow motion trauma
right and it it weighs on your personal
relationships your finances your time
and you live in fight or flight for a
couple of years
and then you finally wake up and you
realize your identity is different you
don't know where you are what i should
be doing because i've been having to
keep somebody else
alive and okay for the last couple of
years and that's why ask if you sat in
it not in your brother and sister
situation but in
i lost my mom
and it's heartbreaking and then the two
people that you would hope would rally
around you
are not they're forming an alliance
against you and you find yourself
totally alone
it's really sad because there's no
gratitude
at all i know but listen listen
you're using your grief
and your sadness
and you're looking for people to channel
that on
what i'm gonna ask you to do is to
forgive your brother and sister stop
responding to them and move on your mom
chose you for a reason it may be just
why what we're seeing right now why she
chose you
because she knew they were immature and
they were um not people of integrity and
so she chose you
to handle the estate
have you done right by that estate
yes
have you ever stolen a dime
did you honor your mother in her last
few years
yes
then i want you to go to sleep with
peace in your heart your brother and
sister no longer get a vote and that's
hard to say they no longer get a vote
and i want you to forgive them and stop
taking those calls
stop taking the abuse stop
giving yourself other jobs in order to
make people who are not well and who are
taking crap out on you to try to make
them happy because you're not it's it's
throwing water into an endless well
you'll never fill it up
you did right ruth and now it's time to
grieve your mom and then come up with
the next chapter of ruth's life which
unfortunately is not going to include
your brother and sister for the time
being right yeah ruth i have to tell you
i have unfortunately had a front row
seat to watch this happen to different
different families that i know
and
this exact process losing a parent the
executor of the will the siblings
involved can bring out the absolute
worst in some people and people that you
thought were so close before that
happened are no longer close and it is a
sad thing to watch
it's a sad thing to experience but the
one thing i would offer
uh as an encouragement piggybacking on
what john said which is so true is
their behavior says something about them
not about you
you ha you know what you have done and
not done
you were chosen for this you have not
stolen money just like you just said you
have done right by her and you're gonna
stand on that and you're not gonna let
any of their emails their texts their
calls their accusations their hateful
words that they are spewing at you
you're going to stand on the truth of
who you are and what you know and what
you have done
and just like john said let that give
you peace tonight because the way that
they're acting says something about them
it's not a reflection of you
this is hard hard hard ruth
oh it is and i've been taking your
advice i'm exercising again i've even
signed up for a half marathon and a girl
room
that's awesome
discovered this graceful purpose on
youtube and i listened to that a bunch
you know and i'm trying to get back to
that point and it's it's helped a lot
and then when someone throws a new thing
at you you go okay so i ate some cookies
today hey you know what it's it's we all
need some cookies every now and then
that's exactly right
um ruth
grieving the loss of our parents is hard
it's hard it's not easy the path is hard
and it's especially hard when people we
love throw rocks at us along the way
and it shouldn't be that way
and unfortunately it is
and it's time to grieve that loss and
your brothers and sister unfortunately
and they no longer get a vote
i'm proud of you i'm so proud of you for
stepping up and doing the the
debate what i call the basics right
taking care of your body and your mind
and
your you know entertaining optimistic
choices about i'm gonna i'm gonna
discover a new purpose right that's
awesome that's so great
and here here's
we only have a few minutes left so i
won't just get on a soapbox okay but if
you
are struggling in grief if you lost
someone that you care about which there
have been a lot of lost knowledge 24
months
if
you're feeling shame or guilt or what
you didn't say or did say or what i
didn't do or how
don't take that on somebody else don't
weaponize your grief and hurt somebody
else because you're hurting yeah have
the courage to say i'm sad
how could you help someone
identify that they're doing that
any time sometimes i'm thinking most
people probably don't realize they're
doing it or are intentionally doing it
when you find yourself enraged or angry
at somebody that you should otherwise
love that's a that's a moment for you to
step back
and take a breath and ask this question
i got this from my
my good friend jordan bunch he worked
for me once and um
i asked him once just as his supervisor
how are you always so
moving through the world so lightly and
he said every time i have a problem i
first look in the mirror and say jordan
what did you contribute to this
and so i have taken that with me forever
and sometimes i overdo it and i take on
too much sure but as somebody who is
prone to blame and prone to point
fingers it's been a it's been an
extraordinary exercise for last 10 or 15
years to look in the mirror and say what
am i contributing to this so if you are
leaning up against your brother or your
sister and mom just died and you were
enraged and why didn't they you should
have
look in the mirror and say is it me
that's hurting here and does it really
matter yeah because i miss my sister
right yeah